and in the wake of the most recent mass
shootings plaguing this country
survivors along with local and state
leaders are coming together to talk
about gun violence prevention thanks for
joining us here at six i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis madison kimbrough
live in our newsroom with what was
discussed the topic is heavy but so
necessary right now and with it being
national gun violence awareness day
state leaders joined a group of
community members to discuss the
importance of gun laws and how we move
forward with plans to ensure our
community stay safe
it's not just in schools it's in
rec centers it's in
movie theaters it's at concerts it's at
libraries and medical centers and it's
it's got to change a plea from
democratic congressman stephen horsford
on the topic of gun violence as he and
congresswoman susie lee held a round
table discussion friday discussing the
need for stricter gun laws jamie bonnell
with the nevada chapter of moms demand
action for gun sense in america says as
a gun owner herself she and her family
believes more needs to be done to ensure
those with weapons are properly equipped
to handle them it doesn't bother me to
have background checks it doesn't bother
me to as a gun owner you know to wait a
little bit longer before i get the
weapon that i want to purchase
and i don't
i firmly believe that responsible gun
owners
also agree in that gina morano is also a
member of the organization and a one
october survivor she says with these
most recent shootings it brings back the
pain from that day nearly five years ago
i'm glad i'm grateful that i'm okay but
you forget how close to that you are and
it's really terrifying to then hear
about other people having to experience
it i think my anxiety now has just
really like gone to every situation
possible
because you never know following the
uvalde texas school shooting
congresswoman susie lee signed a letter
to house leadership calling for
immediate action to address gun violence
and the house is poised to vote on a
slate of gun violence prevention bills
next week
now in an hour that group nevada moms
demand action gun safety advocates will
host a unity wear orange event to honor
the lives of those affected by gun
violence it's at lorenzi park that's on
washington near rancho in the newsroom
madison kimbrough live local now